[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show
much better tech day today we do have
Pat back with us today we are going to
talk about ballot measures but Pat has a
slightly different view on the sort of
outlook for Democrats on the basis of
what happened Tuesday night I guess it's
not I mean I said that it was not good
in some ways but in the Senate Pat you
think it was just an absolute disaster
for Democrats I do I do and you know in
the house it's good that we took the
majority will be able to get those
investigations done subpoena Trump's tax
returns all that stuff is is great but I
guess the Democrats won by a 7% popular
vote margin across the country and only
picked up 29 to 35 seats and 2010
Republicans won by a similar margin the
popular vote about 7% and picked up 63
seats so I think that just goes to show
how badly these districts are
gerrymandered and will have the majority
in the house but it may only be like 10
or 15 seats and that puts this bowl in a
vulnerable position again in 2020 oh
yeah I mean listen here's the thing if I
don't see it as particularly likely that
the Democrats hold the house in 2020 and
lose the Senate and the White House in
other words because in 2020 this set of
Senate seats that's up is much more
favorable to Democrats in 2020 the
Senate raised I'm sorry in 2018 the
Senate races that were up were much more
favorable to Republicans because they
had 42 seats that weren't even up for
reelection if you have a situation in 28
2020 where Democrats end up losing the
house I believe they're gonna lose all
over and so I actually don't I'm not so
worried about that it's a majority now
and it can be a building block for 2020
but if in 2020 with a more favorable
slate of Senate seats up for reelection
Democrats take control I think they will
definitely build on their gains in the
house these things I think are all
going to be related effectively I got a
pushback at the Senate too okay so it
looks like Republicans Republicans gonna
have a 54 to 46 majority meaning that
Democrats in 2020 20 would have to pick
up for Senate seats with the presidency
or five seats without the presidency to
get a majority now you mentioned that
Republicans have a lot more reelection
battles in 2020 that is true they're
gonna have to defend 21 seats whereas
their Democrats are only gonna have to
defend 12 but if you take a look at some
of those seats that Republicans have to
defend those are red states by and large
red states there are a few exceptions
like Susan Collins and Maine Cory
Gardner in Colorado but the Republicans
are not gonna have a tough time winning
their elections in say Wyoming and Utah
like they're they're gonna be totally
fine they're Democrats on the other hand
have to defend doug jones the seat in
alabama that's gonna be enough he'll
battle even jeanne shaheen seat in New
Hampshire so I just don't I just don't
see the path to Democrats winning either
four seats and the presidency or five
seats without the president's seat the
chances I'm taking the Senate in 2020 is
really really low and that's a result of
the fact that they weren't even able to
you know make up any ground or just lose
one or two seats that this in this
election you know I actually looked at
the map yesterday morning and I don't
remember exactly how I put it together
but I did find a not crazy path to four
seats and of course all of this assumes
that Donald Trump loses in 2020 which is
by no means a foregone conclusion like
I'm right there saying if we don't play
this extremely precisely Trump crushes
us in 2020 but when I looked at it
assuming that we build the lead and like
assuming that the blue push continues
and the house lead is extended and Trump
loses in 2020 which are big assumptions
no doubt I actually did find a path for
Democrats to take over the Senate that
what that wasn't crazy we should maybe
do that next week I don't have it in
front of me but I listen if your point
is that this is by no means indicative
of some massive momentum that will
definitively carry down
Kratts to victory in 2020 oh I'm right
there with you and I think 2020 could be
a disaster for Democrats and and one
more point just to wrap up my case here
the swing states Democrats did not
perform well at all in Florida they lost
the governor's race Andrew Gilliam lost
to Ron de santis and then in the Senate
race it looks like there's going to be a
recount there it's within like 0.4% but
as of now rick Scott has defeated Bill
Nelson Florida is a key swing state that
you really got a win maybe you can kind
of get away with not winning it if you
sweep the rest of the races but Florida
is key and also Iowa that was a swing
state in 2008 that Obama won well
Democrats didn't win there and in the
Ohio governor's race the Republican Mike
DeWine won there too so there are
definitely reasonable concern
you mentioned Trump's chances of getting
reelected it's probably about 50/50
right now I'd say given his approval
numbers who knows where the economy will
be in two years but hey the last three
presidents won re-election so we better
get to work we better get to work
especially in those swing states yeah I
would actually argue that it's better
than 5050 I think with a 40% approval
Trump wins and the reason I think that
is that most of the country doesn't vote
the power of incumbency is absolutely
huge there's this implicit fear of
changing who's there and the potential
shake-up that people perceive that that
would lead to although I disagree with
that so I think that with a 40 percent
approval rating between now and 2020 I
think Trump's chances are better than
50/50 but there's going to be plenty of
time plenty of time to think about all
of that
some ballot measures Pat what were your
favorite ballot measures that passed I
really like Florida reinstating voting
rights for convicted felons and in fact
that could be something that impacts the
2020 election in Florida because there's
about a million and a half Floridians
who are expected to get their voting
rights back as a result of this measure
we saw transgender rights upheld here in
Massachusetts no surprise that that was
going to happen what else did you see
that you like
well sticking with Florida for a second
question nine tide two completely
unrelated issues together which I always
find hilarious
indoor vaping and offshore drilling now
it was passed so both those things are
banned but how can you how can you
justify bundling those two issues yeah I
mean is it conceivable that you might
not really care about people vaping
indoors but you really don't want
offshore drilling like I I actually
don't know the genesis of that and I'm
sure there is an explanation as to why
they're connected I've connected
conducted polling on this and 99.9% of
people hate vapors especially those who
vape indoors so I could see why you
would bundle those two issues together
if you want to get rid of offshore
drilling so really it's sort of like
you're assuming no one wants vaping
indoors and you might as well just tie
it to anything you think can get passed
because then it's like then you can get
rid of the indoor vaping while you're at
it
that's actually pretty brilliant in some
way yeah for a second I mean there was
the the transgender rights question that
passed with an overwhelming overwhelming
majority we're going to create a
commission here to take a look at a
constitutional amendment to get money
out of politics and there was also a
nursing staffing question that I thought
was going to maybe be a toss up maybe
the the yes campaign would win there but
it ended up getting voted out and blown
out of the water I think like 70% of 30%
not even close
yeah from from the way that that was
sucking up a lot of social media oxygen
and it was just such a point of
contention even among people that I know
and are all on the Left that I see on
Facebook lobbying up until Election Day
on that issue and it relates to this the
limiting of the number of patients
assigned to each nurse in hospitals I
was surprised to see it end up at 70/30
any other issues we want to go into like
there's some unrealistic things someone
gun control marijuana one big across the
country I think Missouri now it will
have legal medical marijuana so good
stuff I think yeah a la a bunch of these
I discussed yesterday and and ones that
I didn't are that North Carolina and
Arkansas passed new voter ID laws and of
course the the yes on those was promoted
extensively with this voter fraud
a sort of Sasquatch or Bigfoot
you know imaginary monster that's there
which doesn't actually really exist and
those past and now we have to see
whether there are going to be further
challenges to those on the basis of the
Voting Rights Act although as you
remember Pat that was gutted in 2013 and
did like this is they're doing exactly
what we said they would do as soon as
you ease VRA regulations and and if
you're surprised you haven't been paying
attention
yeah you just gave some some downsides
there I'm gonna give a little bit of
hope I'm gonna come back at you with the
fact that in three out of the four
states where Medicaid expansion was up
at the ballot it passed I'll take a win
I'll take that one yes no doubt there
were way and you know the thing is we
talked about how the United States is
probably anywhere from two to ten kind
of different countries if you look at
regions and culture and political
orientation and economics in a lot of
ways if you are in a state like
Massachusetts and I'm not saying
everything is great here I'm not saying
I voted for the current Republican
governor but I am saying that we are
insulated from a lot of what is going on
at the federal level and it is a great
thing to see a lot of states making
really good progressive decisions on
issues isn't it clear at this point pat
that the marijuana legalization
direction is irreversible and it is
going to continue going and going and
going
oh yeah even conservatives now I think
favor marijuana legalization because you
have that libertarian streak on the
right that is starting to win out so I
think that's going to end up taking over
the entire country I don't think it's
gonna happen like how it happened with
gay marriage with the courts getting
involved it will happen state-by-state
but yeah with it we're in a we're on a
winning March I think on this issue and
you wrap this up I question on that is
going to be the the scheduling that the
scheduling is federally what it is
that's going to have to kind of
eventually come around I was just going
to say ballot questions I'm a huge
fan of them direct democracy is I think
the way to go especially in the Internet
age so I'm all for having more and more
questions I think we should do this
every single year maybe like the five
most important issues should be up for a
direct vote maybe not so much the wonky
stuff the things that people would
really have to research to understand
but basic stuff like marijuana
legalization absolutely put that up to a
vote well the opponents would say a lot
of research is necessary on that one to
really understand the dangers and evils
of marijuana legalization but for a lot
of us it's just sort of like yeah that
should not be something you go to prison
for period and it's pretty easy to
figure out yeah but it's certainly less
wonky than like nursing staffing limits
most people don't work in that field and
don't have any understanding of all that
stuff I'm glad that we decided not to
talk about how poorly my election
predictions were yes indeed the
Democrats did take the Senate the house
as I predicted but they got walloped in
the Senate man and I think I'm not gonna
be working for 538 or any of those
prediction sites anytime soon Pat will
not be making any more predictions
period and that is now part of his
contract and we be talking about that
affair right after my livestream on
Tuesday night so are we getting to the
end Pat of the tech difficulties I think
that we kind of are I mean we've solved
a lot of issues that we do have to deal
with your audio still and I know people
continue to contact me about that I
think we know what the issue is and we
are going to hopefully get that dealt
with by Monday but the production value
I feel like is significantly improved
now yeah now we think we at least have
the internet issue solved we traced it
back to a hub that we were using that
connects you know all of our you know a
TriCaster and our skype computer and the
editing computer and all the different
equipment that we have here and I think
we're going to have to destroy that hub
that was causing us so much turmoil
maybe smash it with a baseball bat maybe
throw it out of the window throw it at
an innocent bystander we have to do
something with it because that was a
headache for three or four days on my
end yeah I am totally in favor of an
office space style
destruction of the hub let's just make
sure we don't commit any crimes or
injure anybody in so doing and beyond
that you know have at it so maybe maybe
more information about that next week
thanks to all of our new members new
patrons everybody who has access to the
bonus show we've got a couple years that
are going to be an uphill battle but we
are here and we're gonna do it and I'm
glad that you're going to be with us the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]